foreign
YouTube channel this session will
introduce you to the teak intermodude
its widgets and their users
after that using these widgets we will
create a dollar to Rupee converter but
before we begin if you love watching
Tech videos subscribe to our Channel
like the tutorial and hit that Bell icon
to now miss an update and I hope the
screen is clearly visible and the audio
is fine if yes please type in yes in the
chat section below and if there are any
issues to let us know
before starting let us have a simple
question to brush up owner knowledge and
your question is
list Tuple and range are the dash of
data types and your options are
sequence types binary types Boolean
types or none of the mentioned above
please answer in the comment section
below and we'll update the correct
answer in the pin comment you can pause
the video give it a thought and answer
in the comment section
and and insightful for you guys
if you are focused on building strong
foundational skills for career growth in
that case you can check out a free
course to Learn Python Basics with a
completion certificate from scale up by
simply loan you can check the python
Basics free scale of course with the
link in the description box below
and with that we will start our tutorial
for tick into
so first we will create a folder
I'll move to C drive
and in Python projects I will
create a folder with the name
taken to a tutorial
and inside I will open the command
prompt
and write the command code space period
and press enter to open my ideally that
is I am using the visual studio code you
can use any idea you want
or you have your hands on
so now we will make a file
and name it as
TT dot t y
you would be amazed to know that there
are various GUI Frameworks for python
but only take enter is included in the
standard library that is if you install
the python it would come along with that
only you don't need to install it again
or write any command to install it again
and tkinter has a number of advantages
the same code friends on Windows Mac OS
and Linux since it is cross-platform
oriented
and in contrast to other Frameworks
teakinter is lightweight and generally
simple to use this makes it an appealing
option for creating GUI apps in Python
so starting with first we'll import take
inter module for that we will write a
command import
and will use an allies here
and we'll import it as TK
so first we need to create a taken term
window
and we will add a single widget in that
and show you guys how we will create
that window
so
first you will get your python ideally
open
and just import the teak enter module as
we have imported here
and now to make the window we'll write a
command
window
equal to
TK but we have imported
and
we'll write TK
an enclosed Circle brackets
here window is an instance of take
interest TK class
now we will create a new window and
assign it to the variable window
so this is the TK class
now when we write window dot main Loop
so it will repeat the loop and when we
add widgets in it it will keep on
repeating and it will show you the
window with all the widgets so first
we'll save this file and run it
you can see that we have the tick enter
window here
so this is how you create a ticket to
window
now moving on
now we will set the title for the tank
inter window
I will show you again as it was showing
TK
it's showing TK so we will change the
title for the take enter window and to
change that we will write a command
window
Dot
title
and in the circular brackets we will
write the title we want for a ticket
window
I will write
simple and tick enter tutorial
so yeah
I will save this and run this file for
you guys
so you can see that
it has shown the title so you just
stretch it
and you can see
the title here so we can stretch the
take into window
till we have not set the resizable
method false folds if we set it as folds
or zero it would not be able to stretch
The Tick into window
as we are able to stretch it now so this
Arrow it won't be available after we set
it as false
now moving on
after setting the title now we will set
the geometry that means that dimensions
for the take into window for that we'll
use the geometry method and it's a
fundamental method which decides the
size position and some other attributes
of the screen layout we are going to
create
so for that
we will write a command window Dot
geometry
and inside
you could write the dimensions first we
will set the width that is x axis we'll
set it as 600 pixels then we'll write
small X
then the y-axis or the height of the
window we'll set it as 500.
and after that
we will add Plus
what this indicates is 290 pixels that
is the window will appear on the screen
290 pixels from the x-axis
and
for y axis we will add 10 so it would
appear 10 pixels from the y-axis
so we'll save this
and run it
you could see that 290 pixels from the
x-axis and 10 pixels from the y-axis and
we have set the geometry that is 600
pixels that is the width or the x-axis
and 500 that is the y-axis the height
so now moving on
foreign
before that
let us know what kind of widgets we have
in tekinto so in this tutorial we will
be learning around five widgets
so we will start with label
and label it's a widget that is used to
display text on the tick inter window
audio screen
and next we would be having the button
widget that can contain text and can
perform an action when clicked it could
have any action or it could have just a
text without any action
then we will have the entry widget
it's used to get any entry from the user
or a single line of text it also get
multi lines of text for that we have to
set
other attributes
and next we will be seeing the frame so
a frame it's a rectangular region used
to group related Widgets or provide
padding between widgets
so these are the five widgets that we
would be learning so I counted you four
but here you will learn other widgets
that would be canvas
and you would see the photo image object
and other things so
moving on we will use many widgets
first we'll create a single widget and
show you guys how we'll create it and
we'll start with the label widget
so for that we will call the label class
for that
and I will set you greeting for you guys
so grading equal to label
so
here we'll use TK dot label class to add
some text to a window we will create a
label widget with the text hello
Learners Welcome To techinder tutorial
and I sign into a variable grading as we
have assigned started assigning it
and the window you created earlier
doesn't change you just create a label
widget but you haven't added it to the
window yet there's several ways to add
widgets to a window right now we can use
the label widget
and then we'll use the grid method or
the pack method or the place method to
show that widget on your windows screen
or on the taken to window so starting
with creating the widget
now we'll set the text for it
and text
that would be equal to
hello learners
and welcome to take into tutorial
and by the way guys uh some people call
it as skinter high quality said take
into
and many colleges t k Intel
so you guys can pronounce it at any way
okay so welcome to take into tutorial
now
here we will use the place method so for
that
values greeting
the dot place
and here we'll use TK
dot level
and we will place it at
here we will assign the coordinates as
we have created a window with x-axis and
y axis here we will assign our x
coordinate as 190.
and y coordinate
as 210
as we have the window
and in that we have x axis at full
length of 600
and y axis with 500 so we are placing it
at 190 and at y-axis at 210
and similarly with the place widget we
have like taken test three built-in
layout managers that use geometric
methods to position widgets in an
application frame
first you have pack widget
that organizes widgets in horizontal and
vertical boxes that are limited to Left
Right top bottom positions and many
other positions each box is offset and
related to each other
and here we are using the place so Place
places widgets in a two dimensional grid
using X and Y absolute coordinates then
we have the grid so grid method locates
widgets in a two-dimensional grid using
row and column absolute coordinates
one thing is important when you use this
back place or grid you should not be
combined these all in the same master
window instead choose one and stick with
it
further you will know why we should
stick with one only
so here we have created a label and
placed it in a variable grading so we'll
save this and run the window
you can see that we the decanter window
has appeared and we can see
in the text that is placed on a label
and the text says hello Learners welcome
to the take into tutorial
now moving on
we will command this
and now we'll add some functionalities
to the label widget only
so for that
we will create label
and here will not assign it to any
variable
like we will assign it to a variable and
name it as label only
TK dot label
and
it should be capital for label
and inside
we'll add the text
and that would be same
that would be hello Learners welcome to
ticket tutorial
after setting the text for our level
here we can
set the foreground and the background
color
so for that we will write
FG
that is foreground
and that would be equal to
white color
and we'll set the background for the
label as green
for that we'll write the command BG
equal to
green
and now
now to
get this label
stored on your decenter window you have
to use any of the three methods that is
packed place for grid
so now we will use the place method only
so first we'll write the variable name
that is label
and the place method
and inside will set the coordinates that
is x equal to 190
y equal to
210
now we'll save this and
run the file for you guys you can see
that the label as good the background
color screen and the foreground color
for text as white
so now moving on we can add other
attributes to the label widget
and that would be the width and the
height
so
for that
will write width
that would be equal to 30
and height
we'll set it as 10.
so now
we'll save this
and run the file again you can see that
it has expanded itself
so we have set the
width equal to 30 that is the x-axis it
has expanded to 30 pixels and height
equal to 10 pixels
so uh
I have told you that label widgets are
used to display text or images
and the text displayed by a level widget
can't be edited by the user it's for
display purpose only
label widgets display text with the
default system text color and the
default text background color these are
typically black and white respectively
but you may see different colors if you
have changed the settings in your
operating system
and you can control sorry control label
text and background colors using the
program and background parameters as we
have seen that
so moving on
as you have set the color with the words
here you could also set them with the
hexagon
so to set them with the hexagon you
could just write the hexagon for the
color and here
I will
use this purple color or
what there would be a specific
length or dark
but you pull this color so I will save
this and
run it for you guys first I will close
this so here you can see
that I have set the color with the hexa
code
and like the text it's
coming out of the width so
that let's set the width as 50
well let's set it as 500.
so it has 50 close the previous window
save the file
and run it again
here you can see that we have set the
width in s50 and y-axis that is I test
10.
so moving on we will start with button
widgets
so we'll close this taken to a window
and command or comment down this
now
and start with button widget
so button widgets are used to display
clickable buttons like there would be
text and those buttons would be
clickable you can configure them to call
a function whenever they are clicked
and in many ways a button is just a
label that you can click so as we have
set the height and width for the label
we can set it with the same parameters
and the difference is you can just click
and that turns out to be a pattern
widget
so
to make the pattern widget
and we will start with
variable
and two
set the button
we'll use TK dot button
and inside
we will set the text
that would be click me to say hi
so when you click it
I will
have to set a function to get its
functionality
so
click me
to say
I
so this would be the text that would be
displayed on the button
and then we'll set the width
for the button and we'll set it as 25
25 pixels and then the height and that
would be two pixels so width that would
be equal to 25 and
height that would be equal to
I will cite a test two pixels only
and then we'll set the background color
that would be white and we'll set the
foreground color as
black
color is white
and for foreground we will use FG
and that would be equal to
black
and now if you want to add some
functionality you can add it in the
command
so first we will declare the function
and add the functionality for a button
and after that we can use a command
foreign
so for that we will use
okay we have written it here
sorry for that
so we are set with a button
yeah
will save this file and click on the Run
button you can see that uh the button is
displayed on the take into window
so it's clickable soap
that's what make it differentiate from
the label
it's clickable now we will add
functionality so that
we can have some text when we click on
this
so for that
verse 12 create a
and we'll create the function here
and name it as hello
and here
we will create a label
in this function
and inside we will place a text
and that would be
hi Learners welcome to
decanter
tutorial
and now
in this function only we will
set like in the label for the label will
set the foreground color
brown color will set it as
White
and background color we will set it as
green
okay now
we will pack it so that it
gets visible on a tick enter window so
we can also pack it here
we will just use the back method and it
will
get showed up in a ticket window
so now we have created a
method or a function and
we have that functionality now we have
to set the this functionality to a
button
so for that
we will
write command
and that would be equal to
the name of the function that is hello
and it's Capital H
okay
and we have backed the button
on no need to do it again
so we'll save this
and run it
so you can see that we are seeing a
button here and that says click me to
say hi that is what we will set the text
for it when we click it we see the
functionality that is it has displayed a
label with background color that is
green and foreground color that is white
and it displays the text as high
Learners welcome to TK enter tutorial
so
this is about the button widget
now moving on
start with the entry widget
so for that
oh sorry
first we will comment this
and it will also command this function
foreign
to get text from a user like a name or
an email address we use an entry widget
it's
a display that display a small text box
that the user can type some text into so
creating and styling an entry widget
works pretty much exactly like the label
and the button widgets so we will start
with the enter widget
for that first we'll create a label only
and on that label we will place the
enter widget
so first we will create a variable and
name it as label only and after that
we will
go with this
like creating label and
then we will add some text to the label
that would be
it will ask
or what is your name
or we'll just add name to it
and here we will create the enter widget
for that we will create a variable and
name it as entry and now we'll create
the entry widget
so
this is the simple method to create any
enter widget we have created that and
now we have to place or pack or create
it to get a display on a ticket window
so here we will use pack
they will do it back
and will also pack the enter widget
so we are done
now we'll save it and run it you can see
that we have created a label and place
the text here that is name and beneath
that we have packed an enter widget and
inside we can enter anything that's my
name is
and you can enter anything
so these are the basic functionalities
for the interviewer
you could see our other videos too
get the hands on this entry widget and
other widgets to get the other
attributes and functionalities
and use them in any app you want to make
so moving on we will comment this
or I will give you an another example
for the entry widget
so for that
first we will create a level only
and
inside
we will place the master that is the
window
and assign text to it
and that would be name only here we'll
create a form
and it won't be having some
functionalities to store the information
but it would be a form for name email
password
for that we'll use the enter widgets
so we have created a label here
and
here you will
so pay well
use the place method
to get it displayed on the decanter
window and we'll set the xcode in it as
30 and by
is 50 pixels
and moving on
we will set the entry widget and a label
first we'll check the label for email
so that will also create a label
and inside
will pass the master that is window
and
set the text as email only so
and get displayed on the label
now
we'll use the place method only
two
get a displayed or not taken top window
and hold this
I will use x equal to 30 and y equal to
19 include in the same
ex coordinates
and in y direction it would be shifted
downwards and that would be y equal to
90.
now
I will create another level and store it
in a variable that would be password
and to create it I will write TK Dot
label
so again here
it's a small
label and inside we will pass the master
window that is
window and set the text
as password only
and now we will place this
level
and we'll set the exponent as 30 and y
will shift it downwards and set it as
130.
yeah
so these would be the labels
and now
see these levels like how they are
placed so you can see name email
password and now we will place enter
widgets in front of them
so to get the entry widgets first we
will
assign a variable and inside that we
will create an entry widget
that would be TK dot entry
and inside we will pass our master
window
and now
we will
place this at
x equal to AP click it will be
sufficient I think so now we will see
when we will get the display now
okay so we have set the x coordinate as
80 and Y is 50. now we will make another
enter widget for email and then for
password
so for this we will name the variable as
E2 and here we will
do it
TK dot entry
and it would be capital for that
and that would be the master window
and we'll place this
at x equal to 80.
and Y will shift it downwards that would
be same
for the label email that was 90.
and
now we will create another variable that
is E3
and put that
okay data entry widget
and now we will place this and set the
export in it as 80 only
and y coordinate that would be the same
for the label that was 130
so
we will save this
and run it
you could see that name email password
that are the labels and we have go to
enter widgets and it's
overwriting
so we will set this as 100.
we'll save it and run it
you could see that it has shipped it
20 pixels apart from this from its
previous position
so this is about the enter widget so
this is a basic tutorial so I won't be
getting into the get method delete
method or the insert method so there are
three main operations that you can
perform with entry widgets that is
retrieving text with get method that is
dot get method and deleting text that is
with delete method and inserting text
that is with insert method
so we will
do this much only in this basic tutorial
and moving on
now we will create some frames so frame
widgets are important for organizing the
layout of your widgets in an application
like you have many widgets and you have
used around three to four widgets and
you want to organize them so you have to
create widget that is frame and inside
that frame widget you can organize all
the other widgets
so an empty frame widget is practically
invisible you won't be able to see that
if you haven't placed any widget in that
so frames are best thought of as
containers for other widgets you can
assign a widget to a frame by setting
the widgets Master attribute as we have
said the master attribute as window in
the enter widget and in the
label as we have seen in the
enter widget example so here we will
start with creating frames
and for that
first
we will
assign a variable
frame underscore a and that would be
equal to TK dot frame we will create a
frame
sorry
and now we will create a label for that
and
we will
assign the variable as label underscore
a and that would be equal to
t k Dot
level
and inside
we would
get this label fixed into the frame
so for that we will set the master
as
frame
so we have set the variable as Master
here and this variable contains the
frame
no
we will add the text to the label and
that would be
this is
frame a
we will name it as a and here we can set
the background color also
so here we will use the hexa code for
that you won't write
the simple name of the color so here we
will write the hexa board and
we have taken its inverted comma
so now we have to set the background
color and that would be in the inverted
formas only
so we will start with hash and we'll set
the colors I remember
468 to B4
two color
so you will get the background color
and now we will pack this label so that
it gets displayed
on your tender window
okay
so for that we will
write the variable and use the back
method
and now we'll create another frame and
store it in a variable
frame underscore B
and inside we will create a frame TK
load
frame
and here we will create another label
that would be labeled underscore B
and that would be equal to
TK Dot label
and here we'll set the master
as frame only
as we will be setting this label into
the frame suppose that we will write
frame underscore B
now we'll set the text that would be
this is
frame
B
okay
now we'll set the background color
and we will set the background color
different from the above
so you can differentiate that
99
[Music]
x7a
and for the hexa code you have to use
hash
so what you call this color like light
red light orange or anything
so just
get that sorted
so we'll pack this widget for that we'll
use the variable label dot endoscopy
we'll use the pack method
and we have backed it
now
we will save this
[Music]
okay
we have not placed inverted from here so
I will save this
and run it
okay level is known Define so we have
written label okay
so sorry for my same mistake
so we'll save this and run it again for
you guys
so here we are not able to see it
so what oh we have not packed the frame
here
so
we would not be able to see that
so we'll pack it here only so first we
will Bank
underscore a
Dot
back
and then frame underscore key dot Bank
now we'll save this and run it again
you could see there is two frames
displaying that is this is the frame a
and this is the frame B and this is the
label on above the frame
and if we just
swap these packs what would happen let's
see
we'll save this
and run the file again you could see
that the frame has been shifted so the
back method it just packed the widgets
line by one line by line
in a layer form
so you must be careful with that
okay
so now we'll see some appearance for the
frames
we have seen how to create a frame now
we'll see
how these frames can be displayed how
how its appearances are like we have the
five appearances we will discuss it
and we will adjust these frames
according to their appearances and these
appearances can be called out with the
method or with the attribute that is
relief so frame widgets can be
configured with a relief attribute that
creates a border around the frame you
can set relief to be any of the values
that is the flat value that we have seen
that has no border effect the default
value then there is sunken that is h u n
k n in the capitals that it creates a
sunken effect I will show you like what
that effect is then we have the raised
then Groove and the ridge so for that
we will see a simple example
and one important thing to apply this
border effect we must set the border
with attribute to a value greater than
word greater than one this attribute
adjust the width of the Border in pixels
so for that
we will create the frames
and we will start with
border
and that would be equal to
we will create a dictionary here
so for the flat keyword
we will
create a
in the capital letters we have to write
let
okay and for the sun can
we will create
EK Dot
second
okay
and in next way we have to place the
Pumas
and after second we have raised Groove
and Ridge
so for that
we'll write raised
and we will create TK I have done a
mistake above
so this would be TK Dot
second comma
and now we will have the group order
foreign
that is TK
dot rich
okay
so
no
we will
run a loop four
relief underscore name
comma
relief
and
yes
that is we will hydrate these items one
by one
and now
create a frame that would be TK Dot
frame and set the master
as window
and
the leaf
equal to
relief
and set the Border width
that's also the point and you set it as
5. okay
and now
we will back this Frame
so for that we'll use the back method
aim load
back
and now we will create a label
there it is TK Dot
label
and inside
will set the master as
frame
and
text
we'll set the text as
relief underscore name
and then we'll pack this label
okay now we will save this
and display it for you guys
so you could see that first we have the
flat frame then Sun can then waste then
glue then Ridge
okay
so if you want to set these frames on
the left side
or that you can
use TK Dot
left attribute
we'll save this and run it for you guys
we have to assign it inside sorry
I will save this and run it for you guys
so you can see that it has shifted to
left make all these are packed in the
left
Direction
all the frames
so now moving on
now we will see the frames with
different colors
I will just comment this down
and now we will get the frames we'll
start with
a variable and name it as framework and
create a frame
TK Dot
frame
with capital f
and inside we'll set the master as
window
and
width as 100
and
height as 100
and background color
we will set it as
unit
and now
we will pack this Frame
so this Frame would be of the red color
so to pack this we will write framework
that is the variable in which the frame
has been stored and we'll use the pack
method
so we have packed it
now
we will use
fill
to fill this frame in the whole window
well that will write fill equal to
t k dot capital s x so it will get this
Frame fulfilled in the window in the X
Direction
and similarly we will create another
frame
I will copy paste it and name the
available as variable as frame 2.
and inside I will change the color
and I will set the width and height now
okay I will show you like
how it will work
this Frame 2 dot pack
and now we'll also
set another frame and name it as frame
three
okay
and for this also we have to set another
color
so that we can differentiate that which
frame is this
so I'll set it as blue now we'll save
this
and run it so you can see that we have
set the width and height but we have
use the fill attribute to fill it in the
whole external
extraction so it has good buildup
so these are the three frames we have
created
now we have seen the basics or the
beginner for the take into module
Now using these modules we will create a
simple project that would be Dollar to
Rupee converted as I have told you
earlier
in the starting in the introduction
for that
so we'll just create a new file and
named as
dollar
converter Dot py
so if
like it will be
so here we will use the current value
of what one dollar is equal to Rupee we
will set it as current value so we will
search it in the web and
use it in a function okay
so we'll make this project a simple one
or just a simple app
to get your hands on with these widgets
okay
so starting with importing
so first of all import tenter
and as we have seen earlier if use
allies for that and here also we'll use
that and after that we will
create window that is equal to TK both
TK class
and
window Dot
main Loop
okay
now we will set the geometry of the
window so for that we will write
and we will set the x-axis with 300
pixels
and small X and Y axis as 250 pixels
okay and we won't be adding some pixels
to the X so the wire Direction it will
just come in the default section that uh
this ideally would get it up here too
okay now we'll use the configure
function
and set the background color so with
configure you could set the background
color and other attributes so for that
we will write window
config
and inside we will set the background
color BG
equal to
and I remember the exact code for that
here we will use hexagon or you could
just write the name of the column okay
we have used it previously the light red
color
okay
now I have discussed with you that the
resizable function but we haven't used
it
in the former
that is the py file but here we will use
so for that we will write window dot
crease size table
and inside
we will set the width
equal to false
and height also as faults
so you won't be able to adjust its
method height
width or height
and you won't be seeing any arrow for
that okay like if you place
the cursor on the border of the window
now you won't be able to see any error
to get it stretched out in the x or y
direction
so we have
the resizable function for that now
we'll set the title for this window
put that we'll write window.title
and inside we'll write the title that
would be dollar
to Rupee converter
converter okay
now
first we will start with a label
and we will add the heading as
Dollar to Rupee converter only
so for that we will create a label and
place it inside the variable L1
TK Dot
table and inside
we will pass the master as window
and
set the text
as Dollar to Rupee converter
and we can set the font also okay
so that we will just use the font
attribute and inside we have to place
these
in a circular braces
so for that we will write
we have
and it's inverted comma
we'll use area here
okay
and set the font size as 15. now we'll
close the circular bracket
okay
we have to close one more
and we will set the foreground color
as white
okay
then we'll also set background color
and that we would set as eggs are good
B
C 0.
t 0 okay
and that would be in the inverted
homeless the answer it would be
termed as the comment only
and now we'll close the circular bracket
okay
and we will pack it at the last only
now we'll create another label
and
that you will store it in
L2 variable
for that we'll write TK Dot
label and inside will pass
window as master
and text
and here we will
set the label as enter dollar amount
okay
well that will write text
enter dollar
amount
okay
now we will add some functionality and
after amount we will write the colon
now we'll set its font
in the circular basis and
you will set this also as a way
and set its size
just smaller than the heading that would
be Dollar to Rupee converter
inside it as 10.
okay
and
we'll set it as bold
this way I have to place it in inverted
commas
and after the font we'll set the
foreground color
and that would be equal to White
and then we'll set the background color
we have taken the inverted comma White
and I will set the background color
and for that we'll write the hexagon
and that would be a 5
6 9bd
foreign
this purple color
so I call it proper
I am bad with color so you can see
what you want to call this color or like
what's the fundamental name of this
color
so now we have created two levels and a
dollar amount
and now we create we will get another
label and that would be
or amount in rupees like after we will
execute the Dollar to Rupee so that
would be displayed in that level that
would display just beneath this label
that we will be creating that would be
M3
and for that we will write TK dot label
and inside we will pass the master as
window
and set that text
as amount in rupees
okay
and now we will set its font
and
set it it's same only
as
alien
and with the font size
10 and we also set it as bold
so outside this font
we will set the foreground and
background color
and that would be foreground color
White
and background color
we'll write the hexa code for that only
and that would be same A5
69 BD
okay
now we will create enter widgets
so
first time to visit that would be four
entering the amount and a dollar amount
so
in this enter widget would be beneath
the enter dollar amount label
so for that we will create a variable
even
and
enter widget TK Dot
entry
and we have
E capital for the entry and inside we
will pass
Master as window
and we'll set the font
as area
in the circular basis
okay
and set the font size as 10. and no bold
for it
okay
and
in the window first we have created the
heading that was in the label that is
dollar to RP converted then we have
created the labor and a dollar amount
and beneath that we have created an
entry widget in which we will enter the
dollar amount
and then
we will create a button to convert this
taller amount into the rupee
so now we will be creating a button
so we will name the variable as button
one
now we'll pass
the window as master
and set the font
foreign
and
phone says 10 only
[Music]
but for button first we have to set the
text name but it should display
so
it should display
convert
to dollar
convert to dollar convert to Rupee
okay
so we have
set the text
and we have set the font and now
we have to place a command and in that
command we have to place a function so
that it should convert the dollar amount
into the rupee
so we have to create a function
we will create it
create it here
okay
and name it as convert only
so for that
right
convert
and inside we will
set a variable and integer type
and here we are using the get method
to get the text that we have imported in
the entry widget that is stored in the
even variable
and after that
we will create a variable F and inside
we will write the dollar value against a
rupee that is
80.71 Rupees is equal to one dollar
so that would be multiplied with the
dollar amount
that would be C
but we will
get it
oh sorry
okay
so now
we will
now we will create a text widget
so for that we will
create a variable that is T1
and create a text widget
TK
Dot
text and inside we will pass the window
as master
and set the state
as disabled
I will tell you why
disabled
and set its width
as
teen
White yes
zero okay
so you will also configure this in the
function
okay
so we'll configure this and write as T1
Dot
config
and we'll set its state
equal to normal
okay
and T1 Dot
delete
that is
if you want to delete you can delete a
test
one by one
TK Dot and
and T1 dot insert
and set it as its state as disabled
okay
now we will pack all these
widgets
first we'll start with labels
L1 load pack
then L2 Dot
back
then
enter widget
that is stored in even even node
back
and then
we're done
dot pack
and then L3
dot back
and then
P1 Dot
back
okay
now we'll save this
and run it
okay
so we have to create
empty text
empty labels
we will create it here
empty
underscore L1
and create a label that is TK Dot
label
okay
and inside we will pass
window
and set the background color
equal to
it would be e
99
67 oh sorry
e9967 a that is the light red color okay
and here we will create an empty level
that is TK Dot
label
and
now we will
pass the master as window
and background color
as light red only
we'll write the same hexagon e99
678
so AI
press
shift also with that
so
okay
now
we'll save our program
and run it
so we are getting an error
there it is
defined at State equal to normal
okay
so we'll just run it again only
okay
we encode that
so you can see that it's not resizable
we have created the convert method to
create the dollar amount that is we have
entered
the dollar amount that is one and we
click on the button that is convert to
dollar it would reflect us to 82.71
and if we get it deleted and enter the
dollar amount as 56 and click on the
button that is convert to dollar it
would display us as 56 into the value
that is 82.71
so this is the small project that we
have created using the widgets that is
the teak into widgets
so I hope like you quote these all the
widgets so this was the basic tutorial
if you want to learn more you can just
see the other videos that is in the I
button
and at end I have something insightful
for you guys uh if you guys are aiming
to get certified in Python Programming
and want to build up python software
development carrier in that case you can
check this python certificate course by
simply learn which will open the doors
for the best career opportunities to
find the details of this python
certification calls just check in the
description box I will just add the link
there and it could be the ideal solution
to help you build your career in the
right direction
and with that I hope this session was
interesting and informative if you liked
it please let us know in the comment
section below and also do subscribe to
our Channel and stay tuned for more from
Simply learn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here